i want to look at a clip with you today
of uh this christian hate preacher
greg locke okay
this is a guy we've talked about before
there's a church called the global
vision bible church in uh tennessee i
looked to see if they are actually a
tax-exempt church and i was not able to
definitively find out one way or the
other as many of you know churches
quote real churches are able to be tax
exempt in the united states this allows
them to not pay property tax this allows
them a lot of other tax benefits and one
of the rules is they're not allowed to
do politics at the pulpit you can't be a
political organization and have
tax-exempt status i'm going to play a
wild clip for you here from global
vision bible church this is greg locke
he uh threatens democrats that are
watching him
he threatens an insurrection he says
that nobody in his church should be
voting for democrats this is the epitome
of why there should not be tax-exempt
status for the religious wing of
churches if you run a school a church
school
a church-based school
and you're teaching real curriculum i'm
actually okay with the educational side
of a church having tax exemption
but this sort of stuff has to end take a
listen to this
i'm to the place right now if you vote
democrat i don't even want you around
this church you can get out okay so
right off the bat saying democrats
aren't welcome here
that's a pretty political statement
you get out you demon
you can get out you baby butchering
election thief so that by the way baby
butchering
that's talking about abortion so this is
all politics this is exactly the stuff
churches aren't allowed to do if they
want to maintain tax-exempt status how
many billions of dollars
are being uh
subsidized by random taxpayers because
churches don't pay taxes but still do
politics you cannot be a christian and
vote democrat in this nation i don't
care how mad that makes you you get
pissed off as you want to you cannot be
a christian and vote democrat in this
nation they are god denying demons that
butcher babies and hate this nation
they hate this nation
get mad all you want to
i don't care if you stand i don't care
if you throw tomatoes praise god i'm
about to throw a microphone up in his
house
right cnn can eat my dirty socks you
cannot be a democrat and a christian you
cannot somebody say amen
i actually don't remember we once had a
video of a pastor that ate dog poop on
stage to prove some kind of point
i don't remember if it was this guy let
me see greg lock eating dog poop
um
i think it was okay let's continue
anyway the rest of you get out
get out
get out in the name of jesus
i ain't playing your stupid games
a bunch of devils
i'm sick of it
they won't talk about the insurrection
let me tell you something
you ain't seen the insurrection yet
whoa
you keep on pushing our buttons you low
down sorry compromisers
you god hating communist america you'll
find out what the insurrection is cause
we ain't playing your garbage we ain't
so now threatening violence threatening
something even saying the the so-called
insurrection of january 6
that ain't nothing compared to the
insurrection they might do
play in your mess my bible says that the
church of the living god is an
institution that the gates of hell shall
not prevail against it and the bible
says that we'll take it by force that's
what the bible says
that's what the bible says
[Applause]
imagine thinking that this nonsense has
anything to do with the teachings of
jesus like i i'm not a christian so i
don't care about the teachings of jesus
they have no impact on my life
whatsoever but i know people who
actually care about the teachings of
jesus insofar as how to treat other
people and feeding the poor and being a
good neighbor and all these different
things
this has nothing to do with the
teachings of jesus and the idea that
this is a so-called christian church is
absolutely bonkers now again on the
tax-exempt status this is global vision
bible church in tennessee there's
another church by a similar name in
california which is tax-exempt that's
not this church i looked for the 501c3
status and and number non-profit number
for this church i wasn't able to find
one now that doesn't really mean
anything very often these churches even
though it's called global vision bible
church it might in reality be called
something like you know one two three
four five ministries llc and i i just
don't know so that that's a very common
thing that the actual filing name is
different than the doing business as but
at this point at minimum
there should be an investigation due to
the very brazen calls for violence and
number two
if they are tax exempt he is literally
saying democrats get out if you don't
allow democrats in your church
you're doing politics and you shouldn't
be a tax-exempt institution horrifying
and i don't have the number in front of
me but i've previously told you
billions of dollars a year
go in the form of tax exemptions
to churches many of which do political
advocacy advocacy which they should not
be doing